I arrived at Sundance on a beautiful
blue sky day I still remember the
whispering music of the quaking Aspens
and the site of majestic mount
toogas in that magical setting Redford
laid out his radical
Vision wellestablished screenwriters
directors actors would Mentor bold
independent filmmakers early in their
careers Redford wanted to build a
community that honored creative Freedom
risk-taking a culture of generosity
which meant the world to me and
storytellers from underrepresented
communities for me this was love at
first sight my journey might have ended
at that first visit to Sundance but I
wanted more and I asked for five minutes
with Bob before leaving the mountain and
I got those five minutes